let me start by thanking the organizers
Martin won and everybody else for
inviting me here to a series of very
exciting and stimulating workshops so I
know from yesterday afternoon discussion
maybe I will excite a lot of debate
about enhancers and their target genes
so so I decided that might be a better
topic to talk about so we start by
saying that we have been working in the
encode consortium for quite a number of
years and all this work has been done in
a context of encode and as part of the
encode they are the goal of the encode
is to catalog all functional elements in
the human and mouse genome and to
develop freely available resources for
the research community and I borrowed
this flight from nhi Mike Pazin
and basically here is how the
construction looks like in terms of
organization so there are data producing
groups who produce a large variety of
data RNA seek chip seek of TFS and
histone modifications DNA methylation
DNA DNA hypersensitivity RNA binding
proteins and then the ISA data
Coordination Center that takes all these
data and and also perhaps equally
importantly the metadata associated with
these data sets put it in a unified
place so that people can easily query
the data in the metadata I my row is a
heading data analysis center that
performs a lot of the analyses that are
required by the consortium to be useful
and one major charge is to produce
something called the Encyclopedia which
comes from
I think the EES encyclopedia encode
which is a collection of analysis
results that might be useful for the
broader community so people are asking
where is the encyclopedia so so far
encode has generated a thousands of
experiments as use I we saw from those
talk yesterday about picking the
experiments so hundreds of DNA's seek
these numbers are actually more than
these so 200 plus is a little dated so
we have hundreds of DNA seek and over a
thousand chip seek 40s and so on and how
do we integrate these very different
types of experiments and essays to find
functional and efficient so what we are
working on to be included in this
encyclopedia includes a number of things
for example like expression of teens
across a panel of cell types
transcription start sites and all these
enriched regions company called Peaks
from DNA sick chip seek of histones and
the TFS and then chromatin contacts for
example from hi-c experiments a lot of
them conducted by York Decker and then
chia-pet
by Mike Schneider and then also you have
heard semi automated genome annotations
like cigars by come hmm and segue and
then today I'm going to talk about these
two components one is candidate
regulatory elements especially enhancers
and also the target genes of these
enhancers
so the goal of predicting is enhancers
include a number of ways because
enhancer protection has been pursued
very actively by quite a few groups so
far and our goal for protecting
enhancers as part of the Encyclopedia
has a number of distinct goals for
example the first one is we want to we
are in favor more in favor of
unsupervised method so that we can apply
the method broadly to a large number of
cell types in both human and mouse and
then the second goal we like is to try
to incorporate multiple epigenetic
features such as DNA seed and in k-27 AC
which have been shown to be really good
markers for enhancer activity so we want
to apply broadly to cell types so we
actually have been working this my lab
has been working on this for quite a bit
of time until we we realized that we
really should work on these methods
using encode mouse data so the groups in
encode who work on Mouse have come up
with a really nice collection of data so
very nice the formulated matrix of
developmental time points and cell types
in Mouse with a large panel of
experiments so histone marks chip seek
have been made by penguin with a panel
of histone marks and RNA seek data have
been produced by popper world's lab DNA
methylation bio by Joe Ecker
and then DNA's seek now for the Hope
matrix but for a subset of the cell
types and time points by John's name so
here is the matrix I'm talking about
so there are developmental time points
embryo 11.5 days and so on so forth p0
is the day of birth and with these these
these are the first three categories of
data the whole matrix will be populated
by the end of this stage of the encode
project you see some white cells here
but those are still being filled in
DNA's will not be performed on these
whole matrix unfortunately but it will
give us actually DNA s is more available
for human data so we we really wanted to
test as many features as possible for
predicting enhancers so we focused our
effort Oh 11.5 they datasets so once we
have formulated our message that we can
then apply it to the entire matrix and
then predict enhancers in a cell
type-specific
and time point specific manner so in
addition to these data we also have
another group participating in encode
land Pinocchio and XO fizzle they have
been building these visa database which
has a lot of experimental validations of
enhancers using transgenic mouse
experiments and I think you have heard
about these kind of data from nada the
day before yesterday so so you're
probably familiar with that now
so Vista has over 2000 regions they have
been tested so what they do is they
clone the region and micro inject into a
mouse egg and then put into pseudo
pregnant mother and then at embryonic
stage whatever the time point you want
to sa very company 11.5 and then you
will staying for the reporter gene and
then to see whether or not the region
that you have designed is functional at
that time point so this is laborious
experiments but one thing that's highly
high support about this experiment is it
you can see the entire embryo so if this
construct is active any tissue type in
the embryo you will see it so it's
parallel in terms of cell type so so
these two thousand regions are active in
selected types of cells and war Lin and
for sub brain regions and in heart and
neural tube and whatever there are
hundreds of active enhancers so we
decided to take these data said albeit
maybe they have force negative regions
but it's highly accurate for the region
C has tested and we decided to use this
as our training and testing data set for
developing enhancers no I didn't mean
that
so for each of these cell types we have
hundreds of regions that are active so
collectively they have tested two
thousand of them so we just take the
ones that are active say England treat
them as positives and then the rest of
the regions and negatives even if some
of them may be active in heart for
example so here is a gallery and you can
see that these are cell types
specifically is pretty distinct yes
oh so in their data set because of their
testing regions that are likely to be
active so they don't have a lot of them
that are negative but if you just
randomly take regions in the genome and
test them I all say the in data maybe 10
to 20 percent are completely negative
but these again these are regions that
they had reasons to believe that may be
active they haven't tested that all of
the reasons that region said that they
thought might be active might be
negative to begin uh yes still some of
them are completely negative different
times before the experiment is done or
ever could be active in other time
points of development yes so taking all
the caveats in mind so this is still a
highly valuable data set so for testing
that algorithm we we were actually so
maybe I should spend a half a minute
talking about like at the beginning were
very ambitious we actually organized
like a blind test for for all the encode
members who participate and everybody
submitted their predictions and people
were using all kinds of features you
know thousands of input features and
doing machine learning on all that and
then after the evaluation we realized
that features that are specific to that
cell type and that time point are by far
much more predictive than other features
that are produced for other irrelevant
cell types and ten points so we actually
scaled back dramatically try to build
the method from more ground out a single
feature approach so I I don't want to go
through the whole process but I just
want to
that while developing a very simple and
unsupervised method we tested a number
of things for example how do you Center
your predictive enhancers in the genome
you can't do base pair resolution you'll
be overwhelmed by multiple testing so we
tested two choices one is centered on
the piece of DNA signal I will give you
some screenshots and you will see what I
mean by these Peaks they are actually
quite peaky and also the other choice is
centered on K 27 AC Peaks and then how
do you rank these regions right you can
rank them by the p-value of a peak
calling algorithm or by the raw signal
of weeds around the peaks and so these
are the two things we really spend time
testing and I think the conclusions are
pretty broadly applicable and we as I
said they were meant multiple types of
signals and when I showed you the matrix
and DNA methylation other histone marks
and so we also considered them in a
stepwise manner so how do we test the
algorithms this is probably really
trivial to you guys here but basically
we just used the bestir positive or
negative and then the regions that we
pick out these Peaks we call them Peaks
so either dnase peaks or k-27 AC peaks
and then ranked differently using these
confusion matrix to compute a precision
recall and and then compare the methods
so usually for each cell type there are
about 300 positives and then 2,000 - 300
negatives this is specific to each cell
type
I mean it's skewed but still not as
skewed as in real life
correct so that's why we're doing PR
precision recall right so this is not
really predicting the enhancer but it's
predicting what this should be enhancer
is active right you're choosing from
things that you sort of already know are
man thousand are they are all enhancers
only some are not active in that tissue
that's what you're predicting for it so
not all 2000 are active in one of the
tissues tested some of them are negative
everywhere okay I agree with your saying
you know it's more a tissue specificity
prediction I mean I don't know if it's
more or less but it's we're trying to
predict both tissue specificity and
whether or not it is an enhancer in one
shot yes right okay
I mean if you have confusion ask me
later again so here is a typical PR
curve and precision recall and so here
you can see that you we have different
ranking scheme and then different ways
of focusing on which kind of signal so
the reason that I'm only showing PNAS
and k-27 HD in this plot is they are
actually the best single features we
have tested exhaustively each of the
features beforehand and then these two
come out to be the best single features
and then we're trying to combine them so
as you can see here there is a straight
line here so those are the regions out
of the two thousand that are negatives
in a particular tissue type hindbrain
here
founders and then the results is after
all the testing we came up with a very
simple and unsupervised approach so if
we send our predictions on dnase peaks
and it works better than on k-27 ACPs
which kind of makes sense so next figure
probably shows so hang on with that sort
and under the other one is we have
incorporated additional data such as DNA
methylation p 4m e 1 2 3 k 9 AC so these
are all active marks and then these 2 k
constant a cm is 3 K Nyami 3 these two
are repressive marks if you include
these using like simple approaches such
as linear regression logistic regression
they do not improve the performance at
all I'm not saying that they're not
helpful but just in our evaluation
scheme in the help so here is the the
method is actually extremely simple you
have dnase peaks so for example you can
see in is raw signal they are very peaky
so you can pick the center of the region
and then you have k-27 AC signal so here
from here you can see that Y picking the
peak of DNA signal is more effective
than k-27 AC because the k-27 AC is on
histone is a histone mark so it's on
histone regions and usually these
enhancer you know TFS they bind open
chromatin regions so dnase peaks are
more accurate there they're actually at
the troughs of Catan is happening
seasonal so we pick them and then we
individually rank them with their
signals and then we just simply average
their wings and then at the end we
predict an enhancer region that has a
centered on the DNA's peak but has the
sides of the k-27 in speak so at the end
of here is our prediction okay so here
is an example
predicted region that is beautifully at
the the
I speak flanked by k-27 AC peaks and
then this region happens to be one of
the positives in neuro tube so you can
see if you this is the region that was
tested by by in Vista overlaps almost
perfectly but it's not the same region
so if you take this region and inject it
in your mouse you see a strong singing
in neuro tube so I have I don't know how
I'm doing with time but there is a
visualization tool that your you can all
try out with human and mouse so for
example you can pick each cell type with
with data available for example any of
these you can check one of them and then
you know for example what time I just
picked one like the pens prediction so
this is how it looks like for each one
of them so very often you will see that
there is a DNA speak basically in you
know they they have these peak and
trough relationship with the k-27 AC so
here is our prediction and the overlay
doesn't work quite well because the
DNA's signal is on a very different
scale as the k-27 AC we're still
thinking that maybe using the axon
transform or you guys were talking about
Alex was talking about yesterday and
other transform on the DNA's data bring
them more to the same scale so you can
see their relationship roughly how many
Peaks would you then typically predicted
in yourself you know why that's a really
good question we don't have a good
handle on that yet we truncate them at
20k and usually you have like 100 K
dnase peaks and roughly 30 to 50 K k-27
ECP's we're talking about tens of
thousands of regions energy
oh okay quick then so we applied it to
human data sets and then as you can see
in human we have worked on comm hmm you
can see a lot of the regions we predict
are strong enhancers and also they are
bound by peat of 300 in GM so these are
all cell type-specific and you if you
take the top regions we predict applied
it to roadmap epigenetic genomics data
and you can see that they cluster cell
types very well
so these bands of cell types you know
you can see both you know even even
adult and fetal cell types the cluster
pretty well just as a sanity check and
also a lot of people will be interested
in knowing like gee why snips do they
land in these enhancer regions so this
is one particular example that's
associated with Crohn's disease and
inflammatory bowel syndrome and you can
see that this overlaps if you look at
the whole panel of cell types that we
have encode the first one that comes up
is a 30/70 third ranked peak in primary
t-cells and if you look at this peak and
it has a very strong signal so that this
snip is exactly at this DNA speak
thanked by k-27 AC signal and so one
natural question is where is the target
gene of this enhancer and more generally
speaking where are the packages of our
predicted enhancers so in this case
people have some idea people think it is
this PT ger for gene which is 150 kb/s
away okay and moreover there is a hi-c
link between the enhancer
and a promoter well you may think this
is the closest tagine but actually if
you look at the notation there are a lot
of non-coding genes in between so it's
not very obvious that this would be the
gene you should pick so so we in general
we want to predict target genes of
regulatory elements like our enhancers
right so one approach that has been used
a lot in the field one very simple
approach is basically to correlate the
signal between the gene and the enhancer
across the cell types so the idea is if
these two regions are owned in the same
set of cell types and then off in the
remaining cell types in a way that they
are correlated across cell types
perhaps that enhancer regulates that
promoter it has been commonly used so
there are a lot of things you can
correlate because we are very rich with
different data types we have DNA
sequence already you have to keep 27a
see you can Cori you have all kinds of
things you can pour it in encode right
so we set out to do very simple things
we just say okay what's the best thing
to correlate right how well do you do if
you correlate them and obviously there
are other groups in encode who are using
much more complex data integration and
machine learning methods which I'm not
covering here but I just show you some
really simple results so in order to
evaluate how well you can do we resorted
to hi-c data given all the caveats of it
and then we we tested that using this
particular hi-c data set because it's
it's a promoter capture so that the
normally if you see I see you see very
sparse the loops are very sparse but if
you use a chip to capture out all the
links that have promoter in involved
that involve a promoter you see there is
a big enrichment of things that come out
of the promoter I
he was targeted in the chip in this case
you designed illegals to capture
promoters and then sequence only those
things that you pull out okay so we took
that data set and then calculated the
distance between promoter and a noun
baited fragment possibly enhancers and
you can see majority of them under one
mega basis and then so we established a
training testing and validation data
sets using data from that paper so if
you have these enhancers that we predict
in a cell type we take all the links
within one mega base if the other link
is a single promoter interest of time
and then we correlate all kinds of
signal between enhancer and the promoter
and so how well do we do not very well
unfortunately so you might be depressed
over ROC curve of nearly 0.5 you can use
DNA's signal to correlate and you can
use K 27c to correlate or you can use
our approach of averaging the ranks to
correlate you don't do very well the
problem is because there are so many
regions in the genome that you predict
as enhancers so what do we do okay this
is the PR curve corresponding PR curve
also don't it doesn't look very
encouraging okay so what do we do so
obviously correlation by self is it's
people use it a lot so this is a wake up
call it's myself as a jeweler so what
else can you add so you can add the
distance between enhancers and target
genes you can add the expression of the
target gene right if the target gene is
not even expressed in your cell type why
would you put predicted that seems not
sensible so you can add these all these
features so I'm happy to report that if
you add these features just simply do a
random forest now you actually do much
in terms of prediction and this is very
preliminary result and you also do
better in in PR curve so this is
actually a very tough problem to to
predict because roughly less than 5% of
the links are true positives and more
than 95 of them actually negatives so if
you can also look at the featured
importance and the distance between
enhancer and promoter is actually the
most important feature and you can see
that these these features indicate
whether or not the enhancer itself is
active in SL pipe with not the promoter
is active in a cell type only later
correlation contributes so so for these
let me just wrap up so for this
direction we hope to incorporate
additional training and testing data for
protecting enhancers because obviously
though this data set is very small
insights and that might be the reason
that we cannot incorporate more
sophisticated models we can we test
these features and then also predicting
target genes remains a major challenge
and what additional features can we
incorporate into the machinery and we're
also defining other types of regulatory
elements so can I just have one minute
to showcase another method I promise to
be fast so it just occurred to me that
from the talks yesterday so I should
probably show you that we have this tool
called a factor book
I think Eric mentioned what about chip
speak of encode data so this is this is
a master that has all the released an
encode chip seek data it's in a matrix
and so on for each one of them you can
have you know human and the mouse so
these are the experiments that have been
released by encode so for each one of
them and you can
sorry that's not so like the book so you
can look at one of the TFS you might be
interested in
so maybe Trevor you were talking about
IIF three so so there's uh so maybe the
TF motif in Richmond maybe something
interesting for you so we actually so
these are the results of a mean chip so
top five motifs that were identified by
mint chip and we feel to them but
obviously motif detection is quite a
tricky business so we have implemented
this way so that people can vote for the
motifs if you if you like it you can
give it a thumbs up so this is looks
like a real one even though it's showing
up in 200 out of the top 500 Peaks not
as prevalent as the top one so so maybe
I'll give this one a thumbs up but is
this a real motif it looks good to me
I don't know so I'm hope you people who
use this resource who know the TFS will
give us some feedback we can also let
people put comments that single works so
put your comments and why you should be
here whatever you know so allow people
to put comments so all the release and
code ship seek datasets are included in
here and it's automatically updated it's
linked directly to the metadata and
there are all these other features so
you can look at them across the genome
and you can see what are now added here
by Ning a correlated manner across the
genome and you can go directly to the
data set in encode to see what it is
where we gotta phone so that's it thank
you
I didn't understand how you're using the
motor capture hi-c to do the validation
so you're you know how many promoters
are you targeting and when you can't
target all the promoters or do you
target all those in that experimental
paper they targeted to all the promoters
they designed this array to capture the
promoters all the promoters genome-wide
then presumably find contacts that
involve the rotor and something else for
those things otherwise a bunch of
spurious I realize it's gonna be noisy
and answers and clothes but you still
need some kind of confidence estimation
before you anything you know there's
lots of spurious hi-c country so from
their data we get all the links from a
promoter to any other regions in the
genome and then we have predicted
enhancers he's a good point I have to
ask Joel exactly what kind of cutoff she
applied but some sensible cutoff
the cutoff we didn't we didn't apply a
distance cutoff we probably applied a
number of weeds cut off the capture had
some way of doing it yes we just take
the weed I didn't we did a manipulate
their data but as you can see from the
histogram it does taper off very quickly
as a function of business more of a
common I think one of the the origin of
the difficulty of designing a classifier
that also uses DNS accessibility is that
where the chromatin will be really
accessible to DNA s you expect very few
nucleosomes so the histone markers we
are not going to see them well I mean I
imagine that the nucleosomes have been
rolled out words in between its DNA
success right marks are on the flanks of
this region exactly we're trying to take
into pick advantage of these kind of
that's exactly right
yeah that's why we combine the DNA suite
the k-27 AC and we show consistently
across all the cell types we tested a
mouse there is an improvement
conservation we can um we tried early on
the help from conservation is very small
very small very small helps a little bit
okay let's thank the seeking out yes
thank you